I don't feel like that at all it's just
like if that's like my biggest mistake I
just had to grow up MTV is cutting ties
with some of their stars amid the
ongoing call for racial justice in
America the network announced in a
statement ET on Wednesday that they
would no longer have Taylor Selfridge on
Teen Mom og Taylor's pregnant
wait what she's got a little something
going on in there and that they would no
longer air her special with her
boyfriend Corey Wharton in light of her
past racist statements on social media
quote MTV strongly condemns systemic
racism and stands with those raising
their voices against injustice Corey is
the ex-boyfriend of Cheyenne Floyd who
also stars on Teen Mom og the two share
a daughter writer together
Taylor is good with her so that's good
and while Cheyenne hasn't addressed the
network's decision to let Taylor go she
did confront her ex's new girlfriend
about her past racist tweets in an
August 20 19 episode of the reality show
I don't think that at the time I was
younger I don't think that I was
thinking that it was anything negative I
thought oh well this is funny or
something like that but it's not and I'm
25 now this happened like a long time
ago I just don't know where your mindset
was then where it is now if I don't feel
like that at all it's just like if
that's like my biggest mistake I just
had to grow up yeah honestly and I had
to
experience other places I was in one
place where you had to be so long yeah
in those tweets from 2012 Taylor used
the n-word talked about being afraid of
the black people at her work and made
many other disparaging comments about
black women I'm not but it's hard to say
that I'm not to anybody because of
things that they've seen on Monday and
TV also severed ties with the challenged
Rd Gwynn after she tweeted I don't know
why some of you think I'm anti black
lives matters I've been saying that
since the day I lost my virginity the
tweet has since been deleted Cheyenne
who also competed on MTV's the challenge
weighed in on MTV's decision tweeting
wish y'all had this same energy when I
did the challenge I'm done you don't
come up to me and kiss me don't expect
anything from me you're dead to me on
Sunday before MTV announced their
decision to let the 27 year-old go she
issued an apology tweeting that she was
sorry for the insensitive tweet adding I
was being defensive and not speaking
from my heart but there's no excuse the
morning after she was fired
dee took to instagram offering her
sincerest apology
adding let me be clear I am a person of
color that cares about black lives
matters I believe in this movement and
I'm stepping away from social media to
focus on my well-being and mental health
this is not a goodbye
you